mejores amigos fuera del campo de fútbol
Rivales en las canchas de Qatar el
francés kilian mbappé y el marroquí
israff hakimi están listos para
enfrentarse en la semifinal del mundial
una disputa que ambos predijeron hace
unos meses
y después jugamos contra Marruecos
tengo que destrozar a mi amigo
lo derrotaré
me rompería un poco el corazón Pero ya
sabes el fútbol es así
tengo que acabar con él
compañeros de equipo en el París
saint-germain Durante los últimos 18
meses pasan juntos mucho de su tiempo
libre fuera del terreno de juego mbappé
incluso fue al hotel de Qatar donde se
alberga hakimi para felicitarlo cuando
Marruecos eliminó a España en un partido
en queja Kimi marcó el penalti de la
Victoria pero este miércoles está en
juego el pase a la final del mundial
sería una Primicia para la selección
marroquí y una segunda vez consecutiva
para lebrov y por si fuera poco Los dos
amigos se marcarán uno al otro hakimi
defensa derecho debe frenar a kilian
mbappé delantero izquierdo un
emocionante duelo en que solo uno de los
dos puede salir victorioso y pasar a
enfrentar a la Argentina de Messi en la
final del domingo